I mean like giant flaps of like like
cauliflower like skin or you can develop
cysts under your skin happens with
overweight people a lot of time yeah but
here watch 600 my 609 life I'm addicted
to it yeah and this is gonna sound
[ __ ] up this is a real [ __ ] up I
watch it and I get hungry cuz they the
one thing the one thing about these fat
people they know how to [ __ ] cook
yeah so they usually have an enabler
their wife or girlfriend and then
they're like so fat they can't move but
they make these delicious meals the
other night is my cheat meal this
[ __ ] dude or banana cream pie I don't
have banana cream pie so long my
favorite food give it up its many times
mine but this fat dude a tit and he
savored it so much fat get a hit dude he
came to say how much I went you know
what I got my phone post mates earth
cafe but had a [ __ ] at my doorstep
so him I forever post I went balls deep
in it then homeboy was eating tortillas
of refried beans in this skirt steak I
had my girl making it's not helping me
it's matt it for whatever reason i watch
that i want it you panic in that weird
yeah you panic my 69 penalize encourages
me to eat yep there's also play the
condition also where you never you never
feel full but you're always hungry
pretty good time preach yeah I just
kicked out yes it happened yesterday cuz
i got my diet for my birthday and then
left into crazy for my birthday went
nuts and then yes they start like strict
diet time what one thing one thing you
see from veteran actors is they'll never
eat sugar on set for the most part my
experience always then sugar they stay
away from hiding below yeah you can't
lose your energy because you're there
for you know like I committed on I shot
probably probably 15 hours you know a
day 14 you know you can't have a low a
lot of types of shooting the most
important seem like yesterday was to the
most important scene of the entire pilot
at nine thirty at night that's a sunday
right so you can't have these but there
is a there is a chocolate they brought
in these insane expensive chocolate
éclairs and layer cakes with those with
that with that with the chocolate with
the icing in the middle of those low and
with the dark chocolate up then off you
to the side they sure did have cloth
sade admittances to do it right this is
what they should do it crap service to
the to the nth degree where they come
from they came from some very special
shop in beverly hills mouth as well it's
crazy like i'm talking about when they
had the french pastry chef with the with
the two hat and now i will make this
small design that no one makes in the
world you know timber fantastica I mean
those guys like crazy [ __ ] we missed the
chocolate here and clear I call the
larger maldita long did that's gonna be
so good as a shitty english homework
second i don't eat sugar and i was like
not eating [ __ ] and i had to cut myself
a piece of that chocolate cake and I put
it in my mouth and I chewed it let us
see hit it out oh [ __ ] you that's why i
said to myself i go [ __ ] you bloody that
guy [ __ ] you Brian I wouldn't did my
scene it came back and I go I'm eating
that [ __ ] chocolate cake Nate it how
was it this amazing same being able to
uh what's it was a kid named it did a
little like he never got Ben Webster no
other one Gary Coleman Gary claw always
bro years old he's a security at a mall
yeah man I felt I felt really bad I felt
really bad him cuz you can look at he
was famous but he did anything and it
didn't go with his paycheck and he
didn't have any privacy and uh and and
he didn't like it and see that's why I
said that's why I feel about UFC
fighters this is listening is UFC is so
popular so popular the fighters are
getting so popular and they having less
privacy but they don't they don't they
don't the money don't to me i don't
think the money no it's like you get
like like we like more MMA fight was so
accessible yep we we don't live like
like like safe Felicia Floyd Mayweather
when you go out you got like 10 17
bodyguards big giant by us you ain't
gonna win here and I you know like Conor
McGregor now is almost half his famous
as him but getting there yeah but he
ain't going out with 10 bodies are
somebody done we're very accessible as
ma fighters and even though we're not as
famous is like the famous people like
Chris Brown's and and and and the
coroner will be all the world fighters
who famously
we not as famous as them but and an hour
and hour in our world we are but we got
a lot of lot of dudes that no no our
faces and know who we are and and it's
kind of scary like and it's like you
don't for me I don't think it's fair you
don't add or like we we don't we also
pay a higher tosco to be that fame to
get to that famous level because if
you're Chris Brown or here Rihanna or
justin bieber like they're good man
they're not paying any cost as far as
their body or the dryer brain in your
that earlier for a fighter you know it's
for the to get to the stage of fame and
glory as a fighter it's going to come at
a pretty high cost have you ever been in
a gay club you've been in gay Conrad
what's uh what's the big one in the
Hollywood I don't know the abbey I've
been too happy y'all laughing I'm in the
era Frank Rolla there you go I must have
been [ __ ] shark infested waters that
guy is beloved I only had one guy come
up to me and go you're straight right
and I go yeah how'd you know and he goes
figures and walked away I was like what
the [ __ ] you been there though I i I'm
in the Abbey there's a gay club in my
home town of Fort in California and we
were just bar hop and then we walked to
the next one and it turns out to be the
gay club but I'm with girls looks like
that ok what's it game on yeah what's
that fun and it's like all right well I
know no one gonna try to take the girls
so they great great great spot so much
fun so much fun because you not to wear
I could be gone oh god my experience at
the Abbey I was there with this dime
piece and maybe it's just [ __ ] free
for all night but they said because
they're day they were grabbing her oh
it's like titties ad and we're day it's
like I'm not gonna [ __ ] but you're
gorgeous they must have loved you dude
oh my god mean you're you're my head was
on a swivel your urine I was like a [ __ ]
you're at Halloween a bit you're a
[ __ ] dream I'm a peachy do you like
yeah in the same same thing when I was
at the gay club everyone's like well
that's something like a bed and I guess
I got a nice plump ass I got small hands
everything looks bigger pretty it's your
fault brothers yeah no no not me they
look at me like the middle-aged white
[ __ ] dude I am
that's what i do i was getting older and
I'm not kidding when gay man we stop
looking at me a guy said was a marker
for me getting all I never forgot it
because I was so used to being like when
I was my 20s and teens yeah guys would
clamor they look and I once I realized
on and I walked around like that I
walked around like I'm I'm hot these
guys gonna check you the haunted and
they stop looking at me and then i would
meet gay guys make give me no business
and i was like [ __ ] is going on but i
think in a female [ __ ] heart
wrenching matter yeah my grandmother
said that my grandmother said I remember
when men stop looking at me and I never
forgotten they all said all the older
women went yeah me too haha and you
might first literally like my first week
in LA I went this place won't we hey go
to the fresh corn grill to eat healthy
well there's one Brett mother's one said
Santa Monica Boulevard oh my god would
ever say my cab over I don't know that
was the gay district I have an issue
that all i'm in a purple tank-top some
gray sweat I look like I suck dick in it
you know as older Sundays you look like
you [ __ ] guys on the track number and a
hop yeah I'm a definitely power top yeah
yeah i'm walking on what's the the
infamous workout gay come on everybody
in 47 richardson is my and white land
rover I'm walked in my car he slams on
the brakes he's in the past she knows oh
my where you headed I'm like that's
[ __ ] Richard Simmons I was like to my
cars I knew exactly what was going on
there that [ __ ] he pay you good money
to pay a lot about at the time I was
hiding I was on that UFC money five
years later I you give you 10 grand
grand that's the only got weird yeah
that's not of you here to put it in